welcome back well we hope you had a
pleasant Thanksgiving dinner because Joe
Biden wanted it to be a total turkey
brawl the president calling on the
country to come together during the
Macy's day
parade we have to come together uh you
know we have we can have different
political views but there's we have one
view the one view is we're the finest
very greatest nation in the world we
should focus on that we should focus on
dealing with our problem and being
together and and stop the stop the the
ranker you know we we have to bring the
nation together we have to treat other
with a little bit of
decency but then the Biden campaign
released a quote handy guide for
responding to crazy magga nonsense
during the holidays so if your uncle
says quote the economy was better during
Trump the Biden campaign suggest you
tell them they are wrong so Jimmy uh how
was your thing so you're bi you know
choing a bit over here solid I had a
good one I can't promise you I'm sobered
up yet uh no promises it's touch and go
right now uh Joe Biden though I mean man
this guy it he's the guy who comes over
to your your uh your your table and says
excuse me folks this is a no smoking
restaurant and then lights a cigar and
walks away because everything he does
contradicts his actions okay that
booklet they're handing out for
Thanksgiving is a guide to being the
worst Thanksgiving guest in the history
of the world the guy who shows up armed
for conflict who wants to get in the
fight is an unbearable person but what
are they catering to intellectually lazy
idiots okay because the truth is most
families aren't that divided on politics
this is a cliche my family agrees on
politics I love these people I couldn't
get them out of my house like I I
actually was about to call the cops on
myself to break up my Thanksgiving party
I mean after a third football game you
have no right to be on my couch but the
point is I'm not kicking them out for
political differences but this is what
they cater to moral superiority Mega
people are bad but that's what it is you
have a lot of snacks for a three
football day game Tulsi um clearly
they're trying to insert politics or
maybe people want to take a break this
kind of happens every year where these
guides come out but from a guy who says
he wants Unity uh maybe it's not the
best thing that that's the thing Katie
is as as you know you listen to his
Thanksgiving message like oh well we
we've heard all of that before when he
ran in 2020 he was the guy who was going
to bring everyone together be the uniter
in Chief you know his his inauguration
message was about treating all Americans
with respect regardless of what party
you are whoever you voted for and yet
we've seen over every year of his
presidency he has as you said Jimmy has
done exactly the opposite he talked
about bringing people together he treats
uh anyone who voted for Donald Trump or
or even those who disagree and hold
different values as as the enemy and and
actually uses our federal agencies in
law enforcement to go after them uh he
talked about uh bringing about more
peace the world is on fire right now we
are we are on the brink of World War I
three in multiple fronts brink of
nuclear war and yet he has the audacity
to come and pretend like we haven't paid
attention for the last few years on
everything that he's done and how
disastrous it has been and and
ultimately like you said I mean whether
you have political differences in your
family or not Thanksgiving is a time for
people to actually come together treat
each other with respect and and save the
political Arguments for another day uh
for for him to use this to further
divide people is is pretty
unconscionable so Dr fire I was happy to
see that for the first time in years we
were not fear mongered away from
spending time with our families because
of everything they're trying to do to
keep us away from them because of covid
so I guess we've shifted and I've taken
the choice now to just argue with our
family members rather than distance
ourselves from them well certainly and
by the way you know we're not all going
to agree I love Jimmy's Family you guys
all get along same politics I wouldn't
say that's every household and you know
but for me though if you if someone
wants to bring up politics or bring up
something to me at least bring some f
with you and actually give a good
representation of the situation and not
just you know some whatever makes you
feel right I mean if you actually read
what the Biden Camp put out for their
talking points at the Thanksgiving
dinner it's truly like a false
equivalency or just like a logical
fallacy I mean looking at just their
talking about the crazy magga nonsense
when it comes to the E economy
essentially they're talking about it
like hey things were really really bad
last year things are only bad this year
so we're doing great the bottom line is
like prices are still up inflation
adjusted wages are still down things are
bad they need to stop touting themselves
and I mean this little cheat sheet for
talking points that's all they got
because they don't are less bad they're
pushing conflict like if you read the
book if someone says Happy Thanksgiving
you're supposed to say you're a racist
I'm kid well that's true it's in the
guide actually here here it is this is
the funny thing and it's they know this
and that's why they put this out my
family I know people think because I
talk like this and I come from a small
town in Georgia my family is probably a
monolith of politics I get that but it's
actually not we have different
ethnicities different orientations
different politics I've got lifelong
teachers lifelong public servants I've
got people that own businesses in my
family the only thing they actually do
agree on is that Joe Biden is a crappy
president thank you they disagree on
abortion and guns and and teachers
unions and all this other stuff but they
disagree they they agree on the fact
that Joe Biden has done a terrible job
Thanksgiving an e a cakewalk this year
so will be Christmas because they all
just don't want to see him around
anymore yeah well Thanksgiving is a time
to be together and enjoy the food which
a lot of us did grateful for that all
right up ahead a liberal City leader is
so upset over the spiraling migrant
crisis he's no longer on speaking terms
with Joe Biden hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it any where
else